Amy, a high
school graduate,
is ready to change her
relationship status
with her boyfriend,
Nick.
Hello, gorgeous.
Are you my
breakup girl?
Yes, hi.
Hi, come here.
Nick and I have been dating
for two-and-a-half years.
Nick is like, such
a great guy, but I just,
I know in my heart that I'm
ready for something taller.
So let's
talk general concept.
Have we given any thought to
whether you want it to be
a slow realization
or a devastating blindside?
Um, I guess
blindside feels more me.
You know what?
I knew you were going
to say that.
I just get you.
You do.
Let's look at
some venues, come on.
You know what?
I have an idea, Amy.
Let me tell you.
What do you
think about tapas?
I love the small
plates idea.
I think it's
a great fit for you, Amy.
You know, it's low commitment,
you can leave after
the bacon-wrapped figs
if you want, or if he's crying,
you can stay for
the croquettas!
Ooh, I love
croquettas!
Then we're gonna have
to make him cry.
You're such a natural.
Have you done
this before?
No. No.
Everyone always
breaks up with me.
Mom, one to 10?
♪♪
Mom.
When I divorced your father,
I wore something
more traditional.
This is my day!
Oh, sweetie.
No, you stop it.
You're ruining this!
(sighs)
Mom, can I talk to
you for a second?
(crying)
Why are you being mean?
That looks...
...great!
We have the dress!
(Amy)
I watched my friends
do this over and over again
and now it's my turn.
Blessed.
(whispers)
Hey.
Why are all
these cameras here?
Nick,
the times we shared can never
be taken away from us.
What are you
guys shooting?
But all things must run their
course and in due time,
even everything ends.
So Nick, today, I'd like
to tell you that
I am breaking up with you.
(mouthing words)
Go for
Eduardo and Pilar.
Wait, what?
♪♪
We have tears.
Go for croquettas!
(man sings in Spanish)
Why the (bleep)
is he singing?
No, I'm sorry, no.
These are from Spain.
(groaning)
Sweetie, I'm sorry,
no singing, okay?
Lo siento.
But if I want to hear you sing,
I will put a dollar
in your (bleep) sombrero.
This is not the
(bleep) "Voice".
Do I look like I'm in
a spinny chair?
Please just
follow instructions.
I have 200 of you.
I don't even know what
to say right now.
I'm like,
totally blindsided.
What is this?
Oh, you're giving me my
stuff back in a gift bag?
Hey, (bleep) you, Amy.
Holy God!
Sweetie, you
were amazing!
You did it, girl!
We did it.
It couldn't have
been more perfect.
It was truly the breakup of
my dreams and the best part--
now I have a new
gay best friend.
Oh, I'm not gay.
I'm gonna (bleep) her.
♪♪